we are seeing study after study after
study that are basically pointing in the
exact same direction
which is some variation
of a plant predominant diet
now that may include a plant exclusive
diet
but it may also be something that's like
predom meaning most your calories
yeah so explain that a little bit what
does plant predominant mean exactly
right so plant predominant is not
determined by like the amount of space
on your plate that is consumed by plants
because that would be a very
unfair comparison
uh depending on what you're eating
because certain things
can be very high in calories and very
small in volume i think that the
evidence is overwhelming and very clear
that
that eating this way
empowers and fuels a healthy gut
microbiome
and when you optimize your gut
microbiome
we
derive the benefits directly because at
the end of the day
they these microbes they are there
to support us
to help us to make us better 70 of our
immune system
lives in the gut
and like literally
a
single layer of cells
so thin
that it would be taking a person's hair
like one single hair
and like
shaving it
to make it even thinner
that's what separates 38 trillion
microbes from 70 percent of your immune
system
[Music]
that was dr will volsowitz a
board-certified and award-winning
gastroenterologist that is an authority
on cutting-edge medical research on
microbiome science he's here to arm you
with empowering information to achieve
optimal health without restrictive
dieting but rather the mindset of
abundance his new york times
best-selling book fiber fueled is one of
my favorite books on plant-based
nutrition and is a must read to
understanding how to optimize our health
the connection of our gut health is
directly correlated to our immune system
digestion metabolism hormones mood etc
so this information is so powerful i
hope you gained a lot from this episode
like i did it was a fascinating
conversation let's get started all right
welcome back to the podcast dr b i am so
excited to have you here thank you for
coming
ellen i am excited to be here um
this is my first time in hawaii and
so i'm very i'm honored to be here and
i'm also grateful that you invited me to
come and stay with you your beautiful
family these thriving children i mean
it's just unbelievable to be here and to
see this and so thank you so much of
course i've been actually wanting to get
you on my podcast from the beginning i
definitely had you in my top like 20
list where i'm like i definitely got to
get him here i love your enthusiasm your
energy your positivity towards
everything that you're sharing as a
gastroenterologist i'm practicing that
you guys to make sure because it's a
hard word it is it's a little hard right
oh totally
um but just like all that you share
about the power of plants and gut health
and i'm just so excited to get into it
with you to start with it so do you
think that to start you could share a
little bit about your story because i
know you're really passionate about your
transformation story
sure so um hello everyone it's great to
see you i'm i'm happy to be here on the
show and
you know this is not what i expected my
life to look like this is not
you know the the position that i thought
that i would be in
my dream was to be a medical doctor
that's what i always wanted it was
motivated by this sort of intrinsic
desire to help other people
um so that's kind of just i think who i
am and i can't change that
and i went on a mission through sort of
the traditional academic channels four
years of college of vanderbilt four
years at georgetown for medical school
northwestern for my residency the
university of north carolina for my gi
fellowship
16 years total is what it took me to
ultimately train um to be able to do
what i do
and
i came out on the other side and the
issue is that i was having problems in
my own life
so during this process of sort of like
giving everything that i had to becoming
a medical doctor
working you know 16 sometimes 30 hour
shifts
six days a week you know like literally
80 to 100 hours per week
in the process of doing that i
elevated convenience in my life so much
and i also
had this sort of like uh motivation to
find rewards through food
and so that combination turned out to be
dangerous for me because convenience and
the desire to treat yo self
uh
basically led to me eating a junk food
diet
and tons of fast food
and i thought i could get away with it
that's the way that i ate when i was in
college
and i got away with it then
but the problem is that as i moved
towards 30
i was no longer getting away with it
and i would look in the mirror
and
not recognize the person that i saw
and not
really love the person that i saw
i was 50 pounds overweight so this is
like i'm in my early 30s
i was 50 pounds overweight
high blood pressure
high cholesterol
tons of anxiety
i was actually doing
insanely well from a professional
perspective um i won the highest award
that northwestern like one of the top
residencies in the program they gave me
the highest award they had wow they paid
for me to get a master's degree in
clinical investigation which i did in
night school
so like professionally things are going
great
to an outsider they'd say wow will must
be like on cloud nine
that's not how i felt
i was miserable
extremely low self-esteem extremely low
energy
and um i knew that something had to
change
and i didn't really know how to do it
you know here i am and i'm trained at
georgetown northwestern university of
north carolina in medicine the top
institutions
and yet the the pills and the procedures
that i was trained to use to try to heal
people
i didn't want them myself
and i also didn't think they would
really fix my problems
wow that's powerful
so i needed an alternative choice but
the problem is like what is the
alternative choice
i haven't been taught that
and so
i did sort of a dude thing
where i was like okay look if i work out
hard enough because i'm a hard worker
i'm a type a
so i was just kind of like look if i
work
if i work out enough
then i get to eat whatever i want
and that will be my reward for hard work
so i started working out six days a week
and i was doing like literally no
exaggeration 30 or 45 minutes of
strength training and then if it was the
winter time i would jump on the
treadmill and do somewhere between a 5k
and a 10k this is every day
and if it was the summer time i would
jump in the pool
and i would do 50 to 100 lengths of the
pool swimming
and
so
what i discovered with this experiment
is that i could grow stronger
i could grow faster and more efficient
at exercise
but the health issues did not go away
they were still there
and so i really didn't know what to do
at that point
and um and then i became
very i would say lucky
because a person came into my life that
completely transformed my views
and
it turns out like fast forward you know
basically 10 years
and this person is my wife wow
and we're growing our family
so cool and
but at that time
she was a first date
and we went out to this restaurant
in carrboro north carolina which is
right next to chapel hill
it's called acme
and um i love this place and you know
i was there getting my usual thing like
a glass of red wine and a pork chop
and there's this person that i'm on a
date with
and she says to the waiter look
uh
the stuff that's on the menu is not
stuff that i eat
can you take these sides like the beans
and the you know the vegetable medley
and like
can you take these five sides and just
have the chef arrange them on a plate
for me
and
so i was kind of like looking over i was
like
who is this person
that i'm on a date with totally
and it's 2012
and
i knew no one
who was vegetarian let alone vegan like
not even one person
i'd never been exposed to this idea it
was like a radical idea from my
perspective
but
my eyes told me a story that was so
clear and obvious
here is this person
who is enjoying her food
she is cleaning the plate
she is eating until she is full without
any restrictions
and we finish our meal and i'm hungover
from the meal like i need a pair of
sweatpants nothing against sweatpants i
love sweatpants
but like i need a couch so i can make
moaning noises right
and she's like yo
phase two of the date let's go right
totally and so
this experience opened my eyes and
opened my mind
to something that i had not really
considered
but that i really needed to
what if the food that i had been eating
my entire life
the food that was honestly like
celebrated in our family
what if this is the problem
what if the normal way of eating
is not actually normal
totally
and it forced me to take a good hard
look in the mirror
at my life and the way that i was
reading it
and i decided to make changes but
nothing radical like this was not dr b
took the plunge
this was like okay yo
instead of going to hardee's in north
carolina we have hearties
instead of going to hardee's for the
four dollar meal where they give you
literally a double cheeseburger and a
chili cheese dog and fries
and a beverage and if that's not enough
there's an apple pie at the end like
instead of stopping at hardee's on the
way home why don't i go home
and i take my blender and i fill it up
and i hit the blend button
and just like make dinner a massive
smoothie
and see what happens
and
the
the changes were instant
like
i was doing these smoothies and it's
like boom energy
i'm alive
i'm like vibrant i'm like electric
running through me
and uh want to work out yo
do your smoothie and then smash a
workout
um
and my skin cleared up
my hair grew thicker
and i looked like i was glowing to other
people they're like dude what's up with
you man what are you doing mm-hmm
i'm doing smoothies instead of hearties
so
this uh
what happened was so profound
that
it motivated me to really
change and like
this diet that i was eating i loved
there is no question i'm not gonna sit
here and pretend that i hated my diet i
did not
i ate those foods because i enjoyed them
but this motivated me to walk away from
that
and try a different direction
and in doing that
as i started to feel energized feel that
electricity running through me
i started double and triple quadruple
down and look for new opportunities to
make
healthful changes
and as i did this
these health issues
that i had been struggling to like
figure out how do i how do i fix this
uh these health issues dissolved
like
all of a sudden weight is just melting
off my body
my self-esteem is surging i feel like
you know
the powerful young guy that i deserve to
feel like
my energy levels are through the roof
and so
um it changed my life and i
ended up if you play it out over the
course of a couple years
i lost 50 pounds
and as i made changes more progressively
because i was actually pescatarian for a
period of time
but i got there and i was down about 35
pounds
and i was definitely feeling better
there's no question but i was like
what happens if
and so i decided to just give it a try
and i went all the way and i eliminated
the eggs the dairy
and got rid of the fish and
next thing you know
here i am and i'm in my late 30s
and i weigh the exact same weight that i
had in high school
except i'm way stronger now and like
effortlessly
effortlessly
eating until abundance that that is like
the most beautiful part about it to me
no calorie counting
um
i i wouldn't even know how to do that
honestly yeah uh i just ate until i was
full
and
it changed my life so
i was like
so blown away by this
that i start asking questions
why was i not taught this in my medical
training yeah if this can do this much
for a human being
like i want my patients to experience
what i experienced especially as a gi
doctor where like the foods that you're
eating are directly correlated to your
gut like how why is that like can you
like
expand on that a little bit why is it
that you think that medical schools are
not teaching much about this how much
about diet did you actually learn in
medical school well i don't i don't
believe that there is this like
desire to withhold this information from
people like i can just tell you that
medical doctors we we go into this
profession like
to get the grades that you need to
become a medical doctor you have tons of
options right you could be an attorney
you could be a banker
but you choose medicine and it's a hard
life yeah because you want to help
people you want to help people right
like are there bad people in this
profession of course that's true of
every profession every professional
right but
doctors implicitly want to help people
and the issue is that we work so hard
but there's nothing left right we are
just worn down
and if you don't make it easy for us
if you don't provide us with the
education
if you don't create ways in which we can
implement it in our clinic
then it becomes very hard because you
then are in order to do something like
this
you have to
be radical you have to go the extra mile
you have to make the decision that like
you just worked 12 hours
and you got a family
and yet despite this instead of chilling
on the couch and watching whatever the
new hbo show is
you're going to open up your computer
and dive back into expanding your
education
who wants to do that
honestly
i don't think i wanted to do that
but i was compelled to do that
because of the experience that i had in
my own life and i think that that's a
big part of what motivated me
so why why is it that we don't teach
this in medical school um coming back to
this question
i honestly think ellen that it's a
matter of historical perspective
on the evolution of modern healthcare
like where did it start and how did we
get to where we are today
and the problem is just like so many
other sort of organized systems that
exist in a society
once you set it up right you create the
constitution of the united states
and you set that ball in motion
and you can make minor changes through
an amendment
but those are not radical changes the
way that you set it up in the beginning
ultimately determines what it's going to
look like in 50 60 70 80 years that is
such a good point i've never heard
anyone lay it out like that
so we come back from world war ii all
right it's 1945
the war is over
our soldiers are coming home
and one of the most underrated things
that took place during world war ii that
is not often discussed because it was
such a you know barbaric thing that took
place
is we made major major scientific
discoveries the most powerful of which
was the discovery of penicillin
penicillin changed everything
prior to this if you go back to the year
1900
the top three causes of death were all
infections yes totally right heart
disease and cancer were not the problem
and we discovered penicillin like you
can imagine how many lives are saved how
much worse world war ii could have been
if we couldn't control
infections after a person gets a wound
yeah civil war that's what people die
from like stonewall jackson one of the
most famous generals you know in this
history nerd
stonewall jackson one of the most famous
generals he didn't die from a bullet
wound he died from the infection that he
got after the bullet wounds weeks later
right so now we have this thing
that allows us to like fight off the top
three causes of death
think of how powerful how blown away you
would be
if you were a medical community
and you get it in a pill
gosh that is seductive power yeah
so why don't we go after that
right rather than asking people to
change their diet or their lifestyle
which is hard yeah and a lot of people
frankly
they don't want that
they want to just live the way they live
and just give me the pill
absolutely and so
our health system
became um basically built around this
idea
that there are shortcuts like a pill for
every l through pills through procedures
and so we create this entire health
system around this idea and then now we
have empowered the pharmaceutical
industry
we have empowered the
medical device industry and then
eventually it becomes too expensive and
so then we empower health insurance
and that brings us really
forward to where we are in 2022 where we
have these major stakeholders who are
sitting at the table like i can just
tell you as a medical doctor
we have
zero power in washington
zero yeah because we're sitting at a
table with
the health insurance providers that are
insanely rich
the pharmaceutical industry medical
device industry that's insanely rich
and also at the table are like the
hospitals
and they look pathetically small
compared to the first two
yet compared to the doctor
they are insanely rich
and here's the doctor and we're just
like look we just want to help people
please can you just please be fair to us
right and i don't think ellen that
there's any doctor out there
that will tell you that they like the
way that our healthcare system is
structured that's interesting
not a single one i don't think so i mean
bring forward if if you're listening to
this at home right now and you are a
medical doctor and you think that our
health care system is good um that you
like it that you wouldn't change
anything i want to hear from you yeah so
because i don't think that that's the
case you're right because like they're
you're infiltrated in this career you
see what is going on that could be
better that could be improved on and
maybe it's not really happening and
you're just like stuck in this position
not in the position as a doctor but in
the position where like it's harder to
shift the way that practice is done
we have to play by the rules of the game
yeah and we're there are very few
choices that a medical doctor is allowed
to make in that process
okay so when you had this transformation
which is incredible by the way thanks
for sharing your story um it reminds me
a little bit of me and andrew's story
albeit somewhat different andrew and i
had already been dating for multiple
years but i approached him one day like
babe i'm gonna go vegan he thought it
was crazy he's like i'm never gonna do
that and then over time he started to
notice like wow ellen's like feeling
really vibrant and healthy after her
meals i'm eating my
in and out and i feel terrible and so he
started doing the same thing i'm going
to try a smoothie and he started doing a
similar
path where he just started to
incorporate more and more plant foods
and over time like whole plant foods and
over time he's like
wow i feel so much better and then he
just felt like he said this
gravitational pull to be like i want to
keep going towards this because it feels
so good and it tastes delicious too
um
but what i was gonna say is
knowing this and where you came where
you came from to where you got to with
your transformation did you start
telling other gi doctors what was their
thoughts their response
how do your colleagues feel about you
know how you feel about the power of
plans with gut health well there's there
is a um educational deficiency that
exists and that educational deficiency
is problematic because
for me to get to where i was it wasn't
just that something clicked and a light
bulb went off this was instead that i
had this radical transformation i became
compelled to then educate myself
and i spent years doing that
and i spent years implementing these
ideas in my clinic as a
gastroenterologist
trying to help my patients and seeing
what works and what doesn't work
right this is not just like what you
read in a research study many times the
real world implementation of what of
these scientific ideas or things that we
study
can be
very unique or different
we're real people individuals we're
individuals and we have to look at ways
to make it work on that sort of
individual basis where there's you know
there's a personality and there's
different individual needs in terms of
microbiome and so many things
so um so i think that like there is a
separation between where i ultimately
got to when i started to go public with
this
versus where people are today when
they're just hearing about what i'm
doing
and um you know so
for me
like 2013 2014 this radical
transformation has taken place
and i'm now starting to you know
research this and bring it into my
clinic
and treat my patients and they're having
radical transformations
maybe it's not weight loss
maybe it's coming off the proton pump
inhibitor that they're using to treat
their acid reflux
maybe it's putting their ulcerative
colitis or crohn's disease into
remission
maybe it's their iterable bowel syndrome
that they thought kept them on a
restricted diet
unable to eat beans
and by fixing their gut
not only is there their irrelevant
syndrome symptoms gone
but they're opening up their diet and
the beans are back on the menu in a very
abundant way
so
there are many different ways in which a
person can have an expression of health
within their own life it's not
necessarily the way it was for me
but what i was seeing
like you have to understand that people
see me now and they're like okay dr bees
you can call me an influencer if you
want to right dr b has this big social
media following
um like i am not a social media guy yeah
i wouldn't i don't think i think like if
you're a physician it's like you have an
outlet you're you're sharing what you
know with your outlet as a physician
it's different than like someone like
myself who's not an expert in a
particular field you know what i mean
like as a what they like i don't even
like the word influencer to be honest i
kind of think that you are an expert i
just think that your area of expertise
is something that's unique to your
family so true right okay so whereas
like for me the majority of my time has
spent
like again 16 years of training
prior to coming out and just just to be
able to do my job and then working
really really hard in my job with these
people
so
but um anyway i
in 2016 i felt compelled to share this
story because i do something kind of
funny yes all right so i haven't shared
this story uh publicly i don't think
before to be honest with you this is my
first time sharing it well i'm honored
um
so
we moved our family we were in savannah
georgia for a couple years
and we relocated to charleston
charleston is home that's where my wife
grew up that's where her whole family is
and this is where we wanted to be
and we arrived and i wanted to get this
story out there
and i um
i had i had a contact with a local
newspaper
i was i i basically put together like no
exaggeration an entire pitch and this
was more than just like hey i got an
idea here's an email
this was like i wrote up an entire pitch
and i wrote a series of articles to show
them what this could look like
and i approached the newspaper this is
not the big paper where i live in
charleston this is a very very very very
small community paper okay
and i said
i am offering to write an article on
health and wellness
for your paper completely for free
like you don't have to give me a penny
yeah i'll give you my time i'll i'll
revise where you want me to revise
whatever you want i'll do it yeah
they're just like yeah no
really we're not interested in that
that's so interesting yeah i would have
never started my social media account if
they didn't it was a massive blessing
and i gotta get this information out
somewhere i wanted to get it out and i
thought that the right way to do it was
for me to write right
so like the idea of instagramming
was not something i really wanted to do
but
they rejected me
and
my wife said why don't you just start a
social media account yeah
and so i did and this was not an
overnight success
yeah people were not really interested
in what i was talking about i was
talking about the same stuff yeah
um but you know fast forward
so that's the summer of 2016.
fast forward two years
and
went on a podcast with our mutual friend
simon hill
from plant proof yep and it was right
around the same time that you went on
his podcast he just launched it yeah
love it and um it was episode 17 and it
came out in in july of 2018
and it went viral that's so cool um so
friends of friends were sharing this it
kept just spreading
and
the experience
that simon and i went through brought us
together where we have become extremely
good friends now
um but at the same time
i realized that
this information for the first time i
realized that this information
that i was sharing
there was an appetite for it
yeah people wanted to hear about this
and so
i was talking to my wife this it always
comes back to my wife she's the one
who's kind of like the brains behind the
operation here and
i went back to her and i said
i feel like there's something here
and i feel like it needs to be bottled
up into something bigger like catch the
lightning in the bottle
and she goes yeah
you need to write a book yeah and guess
what i've been feeling this way for six
months yeah and i actually created a
list of literary agents for you oh she's
amazing she'd already done that your
book is incredible by the way i
definitely recommend it to anyone who's
listening fiber-fueled is definitely one
of my top favorite plant-based books
when i recommend if i'm talking about my
top top favorite you're definitely in
the top three it's an incredible book i
love your enthusiasm i love just like
everything you share it's so up to date
it's so
helpful for people to like learn
practical tools on how to optimize your
gut health so i guess going back to that
question then when it comes to like your
other colleagues how what's the general
consensus right now with like gi doctors
and
diet with gut health
there's slow adoption that's taking
place i think that there's a movement
towards this is this is these ideas are
not being rejected um you know for what
it's worth i've i've never had a
colleague to my face tell me that they
thought this was crazy or wrong or
anything of that variety or that i was
hurting people
i think that there's different levels of
enthusiasm for adoption and i think that
what that actually comes back to once
again is look if they haven't if they
haven't been shown these studies
how are they supposed to know that the
studies even exist
unless they're willing to put in a
significant amount of effort to find it
do you get any resistance from gi
doctors that are like nah we're just
gonna you know the regular medic medical
way with the prescribing pills and
procedures is the way to go and you know
diet is like fluff and not really going
to make a difference do you ever get
that
i have gotten that with
some specific topics
um
it's interesting the area where i've
gotten that the most the most pushback
has been again from like other from
colleagues other doctors
the area where i get have seen it the
most is actually with inflammatory bowel
disease
like crohn's disease and ulcerative
colitis
and these
the interesting thing about that
is that i think the the motivation to
say oh well diet doesn't matter
is that there are these like small
[Music]
inadequate studies
looking at diet for ulcerative colitis
and crohn's disease that don't show
like massive powerful robust
results
and so it leads to people dismissing the
idea
and on the flip side you know like big
pharma has
these um randomized controlled trials
that they funds that cost them
you know 150 million dollars to do
to show that their drugs do work
right
so
it's almost like people are unwilling to
accept that there's the possibility of
both
that you don't have to choose one or the
other
that from my perspective the best health
care
brings in the best of diet and lifestyle
first absolutely but when appropriate
and necessary you have healthcare
available to you to support you right
we're not rejecting that totally so
uh anyway
the the irony of this whole thing we're
gonna i think get into this more in a
moment
is that
every single gi doctor on the entire
planet would agree
that the microbiome
is the critical part
of ulcerative colitis and crohn's
disease
that it is actually a disease
that originates in the microbiome
right every single gi doctor will say
the microbiome is an important part of
these conditions
doesn't diet affect our microbiome yeah
and the answer is a resounding very
clear cut yes yeah so
i think it's just moving people from
hey if you believe the microbiome
matters
diet has to matter that's the matter but
because it's not like laid out laid out
in medical school like putting them
connecting the dots necessarily then it
makes sense why it takes some time to
get there yeah the other thing to bear
in mind is that the the pharmaceutical
industry they
um have a way to make money on the back
end when they develop new drugs right i
mean this is how they're worth trillions
of dollars
and so because that they can take risks
and when they find a drug that they're
encouraged by they can spend a hundred
million dollars on a clinical trial
who is going to pay a hundred million
dollars for a randomized controlled
trial of diet and lifestyle right it's
so true there's no one to step up and do
that so true and then there's also the
drug companies like funding medical like
funding a medical school's type of
education system as well which plays a
role as well right well um i think that
may be a part of it there i think that
the facts though regardless of whether
that's a part of it are very clear
in four years of training at an elite
medical school a place that i'm very
proud of my education georgetown
university
in four years of training there i had
two weeks of nutrition that's like
astounding to me it's not surprising
like you hear that a lot about different
even different fields within medical
school and even the nutrition training
that i did receive i think it's
important for people to understand
this was not like hey how do i talk to
my patients like how can i have a
meaningful interaction in the clinic and
help people to find a better diet and
lifestyle that's not what i was taught
what i was taught was hey if you get
this weird vitamin deficiency that you
literally will probably never see in
your entire career
if you get this weird like vitamin b5
deficiency or something like that
this is these are the six symptoms that
could potentially be present okay
yes that's so interesting so are you
generally optimistic when it comes to
the proof of the plants of plants for
gut health and like what if so what
makes you optimistic about it is it like
the scientific consensus that brought
you there because it sounds like
you know you found your own
transformation then you started doing
the research and what did the research
show you
well i'm optimistic that this is
ultimately going to continue to expand
and become more relevant i do think that
there are some hurdles that we need to
overcome that are holding us back you
know for example financial holder
hurdles and things like that like you
can't expect the doctor to take 20
minutes
to talk to someone about diet and
lifestyle if the entire encounter is
supposed to only take 12. yeah
right so we have to deal with some of
these problems that we have
but that being said like
do i think that doctors doctors
regardless of the system
are motivated to learn about this and to
bring it into their clinic 100 yes what
is the proof
the proof is the emergence
new societies
that are focused um that are focused on
like for example
the uh aclm which is like the american
college of lifestyle medicine
right like this they are growing
exponentially
and their entire thing is about diet and
lifestyle
right and part of this
is that when you have empowered patients
who are basically saying like
i want a doctor i demand
a doctor who understands diet and
lifestyle and will counsel me on that
when patients say this
then
ultimately the system has to meet those
demands
if the patients are going to go to seek
that out yeah they're going to go
elsewhere right so what is the proof
then what what do we know like what is
the scientific consensus about what is
the best way of eating for to optimize
our gut health
well i mean we we see uh study after
study after study
whether you're looking at
life expectancy
heart disease
cancer
weight loss
choose where your priorities exist
and
we are seeing study after study after
study that are basically pointing in the
exact same direction
which is some variation
of a plant predominant diet
now that may include a plant exclusive
diet
but it may also be something that's like
predom meaning most your calories
yeah so explain that a little bit what
does plant predominant mean exactly
right so plant predominant is not
determined by like the amount of space
on your plate that is consumed by plants
because that would be a very
um unfair comparison
uh depending on what you're eating
because certain things
can be very high in calories and very
small in volume
so like a quick example
um
so if we had kale
right and we had an entire pound of kale
that would be 100 to 125 calories
right so and no one in the right minds
could eat that much kale that is an
absurd amount right
so it's like extremely high in nutrient
density
it's extremely low in caloric density
low calories yep
flip side
uh if we had a pound of oil just as an
example
does not matter what kind of oil we're
talking about because the calories end
up shaking out the exact same regardless
if you had a pound 16 ounces of oil
that is 4 000 calories
right so you literally have ounce per
ounce
40 times more calories in that oil
compared to the kale
so you could
literally have an entire pound of kale
and the caloric equivalent in oil is a
tablespoon
totally
so when it comes to a plant-predominant
diet it's it's
it's not by the volume it's by the
calories
and we want our calories to be 70
80
90 or 100
originating from plants
um and so
a plant-based diet is like frankly most
meals
are
probably plant exclusive
right completely plant-based
and now a few words from our sponsor who
helps make this show possible
we're brought to you today by buffy
getting a good night's sleep is so
important for our physical and mental
well-being buffy enhances my quality of
sleep with their incredibly soft and
sustainable bedding helping to reset
from busy days balancing work and being
a mom
so what's so great about buffy is that
the bedding industry typically has a
huge impact on the environment but they
decided to change that their products
are made using only renewable and
recycled materials which makes them as
soft on the planet as they are on your
bed and you guys their cloud comforter
is incredible it has over 18 000 five
star reviews and is definitely the best
comforter i've ever slept with the cloud
comforter is ultra breathable softer
than cotton and keeps you at the perfect
temperature to feel cozy without
overheating it's covered in super soft
eucalyptus fabric and filled with fluffy
fiber made from 100 recycled bottles
it's hypoallergenic plus its high thread
count shuts out dust mold and mites for
a healthier sleep environment the most
important aspect of this comforter for
me is that the average down comforter
harms 12 geese but buffy's comforter is
cruelty free it feels even softer than
down while keeping about 50 bottles out
of landfills and oceans and eucalyptus
uses 10 times less water than cotton to
grow so use my code ellen for 20 off
orders over 80
you can dry comforter in your own bed
for free if you don't love it return it
at no cost and for the person who does
choose like for example with a
mediterranean diet
for the person who chooses to include
say fish or chicken
if you make that choice that is not
like that is not a chicken breast with
every meal
it is not a filet of salmon at every
meal
that is like twice a week you're having
four ounces of salmon which is a very
very small modest portion size right
so going back to the the studies then
you're talking about study after study
what is the difference between like
cherry picking versus looking at the
consensus and how do you know how do how
do you decipher what is the best way to
look at science i think it's very hard
for the way person to make these
distinctions and i think even among
healthcare proficient professionals
you really have to spend some time
looking at the body of work
so one
study
generally speaking is not going to prove
anything right
we will try in the interest of taking
complex science
and distilling it down to one study
sometimes to illustrate a point
right but if you are like basically
leaning into just one study to make your
point and you don't have any other
evidence to support it that to me is a
bit dangerous
in a perfect world here's what we want
first of all there is a hierarchy of
evidence
all right it's important for people to
understand this yeah not all evidence is
created equal
there are certain things that we point
to and we go
that is like high quality
and there's other stuff that um through
the
the uh course of time we have discovered
it's just frankly unreliable
that it may help to give us some clues
but that we really shouldn't be leaning
into it because it's dangerous to do
that
so this hierarchy of evidence
at the very very top
are human studies
so human studies the absolute best are
what are called systematic reviews and
meta-analyses where if i were writing a
systematic review on meta-analysis i
would like actually organize
uh and strategically do a review of the
entire
body of evidence
and pull it all together into one study
and then the meta-analysis is where then
i re-analyze using everything that i
found
that is the number one most powerful
thing
number two are randomized controlled
trials which we hear a lot those are
interventional studies like this versus
a placebo right
so we hear a lot about those but it's
important for people to understand like
there are limitations to randomized
controlled trials
it's not the right study for every
single topic
all right and then after that
big population studies like let's take
25 000 people and let's monitor them and
let's see what happens
these are these are our top top studies
this is what this is where we want to
invest our energy and our attention
because we know that this is the most
reliable evidence
flip side uh what is the stuff that is
not reliable
well um
anecdotes
yeah like
uh hey this is what happened with me yes
so like i share my personal story but
there's a body of evidence to back up
everything that i said yes right yes but
like i also know i've had patients who
they smoke
two packs a day
and they drink a 12 pack every day and
they live to be 90 years old yeah is
that proof of a great lifestyle of
course right
um so anecdotes are very very weak
evidence
and um when you move into studies that
are not
humans i am not a mouse
yes no right so doing a mouse study
may provide ideas
but you have to recognize them as simply
ideas
that was never meant to be something
that you would implement based upon that
mouse study alone you haven't even
tested in a human
and then there's the test tube stuff
which i just kind of think is weird and
i don't really get why like
you know for some people that is
the end-all be-all that's actually what
we would describe as the weakest
evidence that exists right like even an
anecdote the 90 year old guy who smokes
and drinks that's more powerful evidence
than the test tube study is
so anyway i just think that the
complexity of science
is that we have to look at the whole
thing and honestly ellen if we want at
the end of the day
to really
have confidence
that something is real
in a perfect world we are seeing
multiple different points of evidence
all pointing in the same direction
and when you have that
when it's like
okay the randomized control trials
the population-based studies the
systematic review and meta-analysis and
oh yeah by the way also those
mechanistic studies
they're all pointing in the same
direction
that's as close as you're ever going to
get to the truth right and is that what
you found when you did the research
about like the way that you were eating
you're experimenting on your on yourself
and then you're what did you find when
you did the research i think that the
evidence is overwhelming
i think that the evidence is
overwhelming and very clear that
that
eating this way
empowers and fuels a healthy gut
microbiome
and when you optimize your gut
microbiome
we
derive the benefits directly because at
the end of the day
they these microbes they are there
to support us
to help us to make us better so what
optimizes your gut microbiome what how
does eating more plants help us in what
way what and where do we go from there
well i think uh so to really properly
explain this i
feel compelled to just kind of take it
from the top yeah do it and um
talk about what the gut microbiome is so
uh it's interesting if
we have known for a very long time
in science that we are not alone that um
we actually are like covered
all external surfaces so like our skin
our mouth inside our nose um and inside
of our intestines
we have living creatures
they are as alive as you and i are
but they're invisible
but like literally if you take your
thumb
and you like take a look at your thumb
you will
actually be looking at as many invisible
microbes as the entire population of the
uk
right there that's crazy and they're
actually so much more densely populated
inside our intestines specifically our
colon
our colon is our large intestine
and living there are 38 trillion
microbes
now 30 trillion is a hard number to wrap
the mind around because it's absurdly
large yeah um but basically if you took
all the stars in the sky
and condensed this entire universe down
and put it inside your colon
you would need to do that a hundred
times
to equal the number of microbes that are
living inside of you me the people at
home
literally right now wow that's a really
good way to put it that's really
interesting because it helps you just
get a better picture
it's ridiculous yeah how many there are
um
and
so these microbes uh mostly bacteria
we've been kind of told that bacteria
are bad
that's actually a false narrative most
of them are really really good and want
to help us
there are fungi or yeasts
there can be
parasites in some cases there can be
these ones called archaea
which are the oldest living creatures on
the entire planet
wow they have been around for four
billion years crazy and you will find
them inside the colon of many of us
and um and then also there's parasites
which actually are not technically alive
but they are a part of this community
and they help to shape it and affect it
so
if you go back not that long ago
go back 20 years
we knew very very very little about what
was happening with these microbes
and even just 20 years ago even just 20
years ago
um
because we lacked the technology at that
point to study them and so honestly
like
who cares
right like
they make poop
yeah they smell weird how interesting
can it be right like why would we care
about the microbes that are part of
human waste
the pendulum has swung on poop
like poop is hot right now
i mean people are like fighting over you
know who gets access to information in
poop why oh yeah there's so much
information in poop it's ridiculous
that's so funny yeah seriously like so
so what's interesting is that like the
computers of the 90s like our 3.5 you
know
hard disks or whatever
could not handle the amount of
information that exists in a person's
bowel movement
and so you have to fast forward to about
2006
and there were two major things that
happened
one is that the computers caught up
so now we can actually handle the
information in poop again 38 trillion
microbes
and the second thing was that we
developed laboratory techniques that
gave us access
so prior to that we could only grow
things on like the old culture plates
and that was like you know basically
like prehistoric style science
and we needed new techno new
technologies and that's what we found in
2006
so
all of a sudden we start studying
and
from a scientific perspective it's like
yo
this is insane
what we were discovering
these microbes
again
they're not human
and they're not actually a part of you
they live inside you
um but these microbes
they are connected to the most like
powerful most important parts
of the way that your body functions
so they're deeply involved in digestion
which is why like i'm convinced that
every single person that i would see as
a medical doctor
they
have issues their gut microbiome because
they're struggling with digestion they
have digestive disorders
right
they're connected to our immune system
70 of our immune system
lives in the gut
and like literally
a
single layer of cells
so thin
that it would be taking a person's hair
like one single hair
and like
shaving it
to make it even thinner
that's what separates 38 trillion
microbes from 70 percent of your immune
system
and they're talking to each other
literally right now
and when the microbes get confused when
they get messed up guess what happens
the immune system gets confused
the immune system gets messed up
they're critical to our immune function
they're connected to our metabolism i
could walk you through the different
ways in which they're connected to you
know for example type 2 diabetes that's
exploding
high cholesterol high blood pressure
heart disease
our weight
they're connected to our hormones both
in men and women
connected to our brain
our mood
our stress levels
our stress levels there's something
called the brain gut access that we may
want to talk about yeah
that
is like
them communicating and working together
and then finally
uh they actually
have the ability to alter
our genetic code
so
most people
expect that like whatever genes you have
that's just what you're born with
that can't
change
it's your code
but what we've discovered is that it's
actually very hard to predict like who's
gonna get heart disease
who's going to get cancer
using the genetics alone
and the reason why
is because your genetic code is not like
a pre-programmed
description of your health history
your genetic code is like a switchboard
and someone gets to be flipping the
switches of what genes are turned on or
off
guess who's running that
these microbes
so you know it's like here we are big
powerful humans
and these invisible creatures that we
can't even see
that make our poop
turn out to be the most important thing
for human health connected to digestion
our immune system our metabolism our
hormones our brain our mood our genetic
expression
these microbes do all of that
and they're not even human
that's crazy so then where do you go
from there
uh well i think where we go from there
is first we discovered this like okay
they're there yeah and they are
connected to
you know these parts of our body okay so
we've discovered these connections
can we manipulate them
can we shape our microbiome or are we
just stuck with whatever are we just
passengers or are we
dictating and helping them or deterring
them 100 yeah and that was the question
that existed and
it took us a period of time to really
come to conclusions when it comes to
that question like do we have the
ability to shape these microbes um and
it was around sort of 2012
10 years ago
that we started to break through
and see oh well if you eat this way this
is the pattern and if you eat that way
then that's the pattern
and
oh and exercise and sleep and stress
and
human interactions
and whether or not you have pets
and all these different things
basically
your environment
everything that surrounds you
is not separate from who you are
your environment and everything that
surrounds you ends up manifest inside of
you
and expressed through your gut
microbiome
that's insane that's really really
incredible and powerful information
and so what did you find was the most
helpful
tools that you can do to optimize your
gut microbiome
so i think that there
are um many different sort of things
that we like directions that we could go
with this okay
i will be the first to admit
that it's way too easy for me to
overemphasize nutrition
and make it sound like it's the only
thing that matters totally when it's so
not when it's not it almost feels like
it's like they're equal equally related
all the things like sleep your stress
levels are you getting adequate you know
movement or exercise what you're eating
do you feel like they're kind of equal
in different ways
i think you know i think that they're
all very relevant
and they're part of this sort of
equation that ultimately determines
your health yeah and
they many times are synergistic that's
what we find
so you don't want to do one and not the
other and i think one of the
i would describe it as one of the common
pitfalls that i've observed
is people that go like super hard on one
idea
right like oh fasting i heard fasting is
good for the gut microbiome
all right like let me
um do 22 hours of fasting per day
because that's going to fix all my
issues yeah right
and it's like okay
you're taking this one idea to such an
extreme yeah
and there's so much low hanging fruit
yeah that will deliver more powerful
results if you just acknowledge that
these other things are there
so i think it's multiple different
things but
coming back to sort of like how do we do
this we have to talk about nutrition
first
we have to because
every single thing that goes in your
mouth
comes into contact with this community
yeah
so and there is no question that they
are being shaped by those choices
that we make
um
we can make choices that empower them
make them stronger
feed them
and
allow them to do their job better
but we can also make choices that are
basically the opposite
and that starve them
and poison them what food choices starve
them and poison them versus feed them
and help them well
so
you know this about me ellen but for the
people who are at home perhaps just
encountering me for the first time which
by the way i hope there are some of you
and i really am glad you're here yeah um
for those people
i think it's important to understand
that i am a believer
that we should
find our passion for food
that we should find joy in food
and that we should run towards that i so
agree i feel like the mind is so
powerful and it really the way that your
subconscious and your conscious feels
like with the food that you're eating is
impactful that's part of the equation
100
and i i don't like
framing because
um the whole idea of like glass half
full glass half empty right
in dietary choices
we could label it as this is what you
don't eat
and that's what you've been hearing for
the last 10 years
how's that working out
yeah are we really healthier because you
have been told to restrict and reduce
and avoid totally right deprive
is that is that making us healthier
humans
i don't think it is right
flip side
if i can tell you where the money is at
and i can show you the way in which it
connects to your gut microbes
and because you then understand this
pathway that is
scientific science based
but it's also seductive very sexy gets
you excited
then you can gravitate towards those
foods
yeah um and that to me is the approach
that i think
like that's the way that i want to live
my life yeah focusing on abundance yeah
and not such a rigid mindset that can
affect your mental health as well
totally so um
so like what is that
well uh we have to look let's zoom in on
the microbes for a moment okay
living inside of you 30 trillion
microbes this is an ecosystem
this is no different than like some of
the ecosystems that exist on this island
right now
or
the amazon rainforest or the great
barrier reef
and within an ecosystem there are many
different you know species
and they live in harmony and balance
and what we want is we want to support
the diversity within that ecosystem
because what we have found on
and this is true on the micro level
meaning your gut microbiome but this is
actually the complete truth on a macro
level meaning like
uh large ecosystems like the amazon
rainforest or even the health of our
entire planet
what we have found is that the key to
these ecosystems is diversity
when you have a wide variety of
different organisms different species
they each are bringing something unique
to the equation
and they can support one another
so that if you punch it in the face it
can shake off the punch
because you have the entire team
available for support
that's a great way to express it and
explain it because a lot of times when
people think about gut health which i
know we'll get into
more either in this episode or in this
round two that we're going to do
a lot of times there's this emphasis on
elimination diets and you know the way
to optimize your gut is to cut this food
out cut this on cut this one don't eat
vegetables especially raw vegetables
what's your thoughts on that that's an
it's an inherently flawed ideology and
it's not grounded in science it's
grounded more in
sort of the uh intuitive idea
that if something causes trouble for you
then it must be bad
and it must be avoided
and we need to be very careful about
that because if we if we behaved that
way
then none of us would exercise
that's not true right so
um and exercise we all know how good
that is for us
but is there pain or discomfort that can
take place in the process of building up
your ability to exercise right the first
time you go to the gym on january 1st
you're going to be sore
and you know that it comes with the
territory yeah and you get beyond that
and you grow stronger and then the
soreness is gone so uh
coming back to this ecosystem and this
diverse diverse mix of microbes we want
to support that diversity
and they are as alive as you and you and
i are
and they're
that they're unique like
just like you and i right we are not the
same person
um so these microbes are like that too
they have their own personalities
they have different skills and things
that they're really good at
and they have different dietary
preferences
they don't all eat the same thing if you
literally ate kale all day long you
would not have a healthy gut microbiome
yeah of course not so
but
what we find is that their preferred
food above all else
is fiber
dietary fiber
is unique because
it
passes through the intestine unchanged
we as big strong humans
lack the enzymes to break down dietary
fiber
when it's not possible for us to do it
if we were sterile
and we did not have a microbiome the
fiber would come out the other end
which is kind of the narrative that
people have been talking about anyway
but that's not true yeah that's that's
that's a bold-faced lie okay um
what we've discovered
is that these microbes
they have the enzymes
to break down and process and digest
fiber
we can't do it
but our microbiome
adds to our functional abilities adds to
our digestive capacity
and allows us to break down fiber and so
fiber passes through the small intestine
unchanged enters into the colon
and these microbes 38 trillion they're
sitting there waiting and they're hungry
and they get into a feeding frenzy and
they break down they process the fiber
and in the process of of doing that
using their specialized enzymes
they actually not only do they eat and
they grow stronger
and they become more capable of doing
their job which is supporting human
health yeah
but in addition to that
fiber doesn't just kind of disappear
and fiber doesn't come out the other end
or at least in the way that i'm
describing it
fiber gets transformed
and it stops being fiber
and it turns into the
most powerful
most
anti-inflammatory thing that i've ever
come across in all of my scientific
readings ellen
well which are short chain fatty acids
fiber is transformed by our microbes to
produce short chain fatty acids
and if you follow the path of these
short chain fatty acids
you will stop thinking about fiber as
being boring
and you will see it as being completely
sexy because it is
not just a gut health game changer
it's a complete body game changer
these short chain fatty acids right
there in the gut
they actually helped to support the good
guy microbes
they many people have heard like e coli
salmonella she gala these are unhealthy
microbes guess what short-chain fatty
acids suppress them
interesting when people get
injury to their gut microbiome many of
them will develop something that we can
we can call leaky gut
i would probably call it increased
intestinal permeability but we can call
it leaky gut okay there is the breakdown
of the lining
that barrier
that protects our body it actually
starts to break down as holes in it
we want to fix that
short-chain fatty acids fix that
they connect to our immune system i said
that our gut microbiome talks to our
immune system
short-chain fatty acids connect to our
immune system transform it optimize it
there are ways in which short-chain
fatty acids are
perhaps the key player
in
optimizing the micro optimizing the
immune system
in the fight against viruses such as
cova-19
stretching fatty acids work on
metabolism help in terms of weight
balance cholesterol high blood pressure
diabetes those are by the way all
cardiac risk factors
and when they study people who have
coronary artery disease they find that
they produce less short chain fatty
acids
so you're finding you found that like
the more diversity of plants that you're
getting into your diet the better that
you're feeding these microbes and then
it's going to help you with your hormone
health your immune function
your gut health in regards to your
digestion
everything everything that your gut
microbiome is connected to
there are ways in which these
the consumption of dietary fiber
that empowers your microbiome and that
leads to the release of short chain
fatty acids there are ways in which this
becomes like
a pathway for human health
and the key you just alluded to this
alan
is that um we don't want to just like
eat grams of fiber
yeah i have never
been one to like count how many grams of
fiber do i have
that makes it sound like oh if you just
eat the same food all day long and you
get enough fiber then you're good to go
right or just take a fiber powder like a
fiber powder but that's not that's not
actually true
what matters is recognizing that these
microbes are individual
they are unique just like us
and they have their own dietary
preferences
and fiber isn't just fiber
every plant
has fiber but they are unique types of
fiber
so unique plants feed
specific families of microbes kale is
going to allow certain people to eat
and you know sweet potatoes will let
other people eat
and then there's the avocado then we can
go down the line
so what about for people who are eating
in a way that minimizes the fresh fruits
and vegetables they're eating and the
fresh whole plant foods that they're
eating and they're instead eating either
majority processed foods or they're
eating a high animal foods diet that
restricts
certain vegetables in their diet
so
we have to start first with this concept
of abundance and diversity
and kind of hammer home how important
this is
which is to say so step one
uh in this is not just like hey dr b's
got this idea that you need to eat a
diverse abundant diet
this is actually scientifically
validated
so in the american gut project
which is the largest study to date
to allow us to make connections between
our diet and lifestyle choices
and the health of our gut microbiome
this is by the way an international
project it's called american gut
but like this is a global gut research
project
and when they analyzed the data
they
discovered that there was one single
most powerful predictor of a healthy gut
and that was the diversity of plants in
your diet specifically in that in that
study it was people who were consuming
30 or more unique varieties of plants
per week
and is there an argument or a case we
made that like what if it's mainly
diversity of whole foods including
animal foods like is that restricting
your microbiomes
optima bill optimization if you're not
eating animal foods because you're
taking that out of your diet i haven't
seen any evidence to suggest that that
would be the case
what we have seen is evidence that the
dietary fiber
and other parts of the plants like
polyphenols for example which are the
the um
antioxidant chemicals in plants
that give the plants their colors right
like yellow or red or purple like those
come from the polyphenols
those have an effect on the microbiome
too
so when we eat a diverse diet
all these microbes get to eat
and they all thrive
when we carve out restrictions within
our diet for example taking away legumes
or taking away whole grains
well there are certain microbes that
were waiting for you to eat legumes and
whole grains so that they could feast
and it becomes problematic and again
once again ellen this is not just like
hey dr b's got an idea of what's
happening in the gut microbiome yeah
this is scientifically validated they
did a
study looking at people who had
implemented the paleo diet
now of course the paleo diet classically
is restrictive of legumes and whole
grains
and
what they
found is that when they compared people
who are eating the paleo diet
to people who are eating a more standard
this study by the way was done in
australia a more standard australian
diet like not a plant-based diet
but a more standard australian diet
they found something disturbing
which is that the people who were eating
the paleo diet
had a major increase
in a chemical compound called tmao
now tmao has been studied at the
cleveland clinic which is the number one
heart center in the united states
and they have identified this as an
independent risk factor
for coronary artery disease our number
one cause of death
they've also connected tmao to
abnormal heart rhythms
to stroke
to chronic kidney disease
basically i'm describing things that are
in the top 10 causes of death in the
united states
it's interesting that that's being
compared to like a standard diet be it
australia
which would include more processed foods
probably than the paleo diet so why do
you think it had that outcome well so
they found that this tmao was like
cranked up on the paleolithic diet
and when they analyzed it they found
that the the reason that tmao was so
high
even though the consumption by the way
tmao comes from the consumption of red
meat
so the red meat consumption wasn't
radically different
so it wasn't the red meat was not
explaining why the tmao was cranked up
so they had to go deeper and they found
that the gut microbiome explained it
there were certain changes that existed
in the gut microbiome that were actually
the gut microbiome turns out to be key
to producing tmao
that if you don't have the right
microbes like they've actually done
studies ellen in vegans
and vegans don't make tmao
because we don't have the microbes
because we're not eating red meat right
so we don't have the ability you could
you could give a steak to a vegan
and at least on that day
they will not produce tmao that's
interesting flip side if you give a
steak to a vegan every day for a month
they will eventually start to do it
right so
anyway
the microbiome turns out to be critical
to the production of this dangerous
compound to tmao
in the study they validated that they
showed that there were changes in the
gut microbiome that explained why this
group was getting more tmao levels
and when they asked what is it from a
dietary perspective because it's not the
red meat so what is it
and they found that it was the absence
of whole grains that's so interesting
and going back to our earlier
conversation about
um
the
wanting to find layers of evidence yeah
that all point in the same direction
so here i am pointing out
that whole grains in this particular
study were critical to reducing tmao
levels to protect a person from heart
disease
and we have systematic reviews and
meta-analyses
looking at the health benefits of whole
grains that have repeatedly
in separate populations across the globe
right shown us that whole grains reduce
our risk of developing coronary artery
disease yeah and looking at like
cultures who have like the best
longevity and their inclusion of whole
grains right so so this is this this is
where the evidence starts to fall in
alignment where it's not just this one
tmao study this is the tmao study put
into the context of overwhelming
evidence that indicates to us the whole
grains are crucial to protecting
ourselves from coronary artery disease
the difference here is that in a human
study
on of people who are eating a
paleolithic diet
we're illustrating
how this happens right and it like
connected the dots it's connecting the
dots we're filling in the puzzle so
you're not just seeing the outside of
the puzzle you're seeing the heart of
the puzzle too well what about what
about someone who's listening and
they're like but dr b i you know tried
eating this way i used to eat like you
know the plants and vegan but like i
feel so much better eating all these
animal foods and like not eating
vegetables or excusing whole grains for
my diet what do you have to say to that
well i i've taken care of so many of
these people in my clinic you know this
is my work as a gastroenterologist this
is what i've dedicated my life to
and
what i have discovered time and time
again
is that if if
a person gets a benefit by restricting
their diet of these foods i'm talking
about whole plant foods yeah
if a person gets a benefit many times
they don't
but if they do
it is short-lived
and what they discover is that their gut
problems persist
and they get worse like over time over
time
and they end up in a spiral
and it's a spiral where they are
progressively restricting restricting
restricting
and i just told you
the number one predictor of a healthy
gut microbiome is the diversity yeah so
it makes sense if you're like
restricting these whole variety of whole
plant foods let's say you have a
philosophy that you shouldn't eat these
types of vegetables look like
cruciferous vegetables or legumes or
grains and you're very very rarely
eating foods like that then over time
like your
microbes are gonna diminish and then if
you do try to introduce it then you're
like gonna experience even more problems
than you did before well because your
your gut is adapted to the type of stuff
that you're doing yeah so um i played uh
several sports in high school
and i would transition from soccer into
basketball season
so i'm playing soccer and i'm an athlete
right and i start and i flip over to
basketball season and i'm winded
and i'm hurting totally i'm dragon
because my body was not adapted to the
difference between soccer and basketball
with exercise your body adapts to what
you're doing
right if you work out your legs but you
don't work out your chest
you're going to get some big muscular
legs but you should not expect to have a
big muscular chest because you're you're
not working on that totally right
same is true for a gut if you eliminate
legumes
don't call me up and say hey dr b i
eliminated legumes for six months and
now it's hard for me to reintroduce them
what the heck like there's a reason why
this happens
the reason why it happens is that your
gut and its um ability
is
directly correlated to the diet that you
are currently eating
and so when you eliminate something from
your diet
you are disabling your gut you are
reducing the ability of your gut to
handle that specific food
and it gets worse and worse and worse as
time goes on and at the moment that you
decide to intervene
you're gonna face challenges yeah that's
so fascinating cause it's something that
you don't really hear there's all this
talk about like elimination diets to
like take out this take out this and
this is better if you do that your your
gut health will be better for this and
there's not much talk about the
importance of the diversity
of plants in your diet right no we we
really want that diversity of plants and
you know just to kind of hammer this
just a little bit more ellen
a few things
we i i mentioned before that like i want
people not to be running away from stuff
i want people to be running towards food
that brings them joy right and so but
there's an issue which is that people
are just flat out not consuming
fiber-rich foods
if you look the average american in the
united states
is consuming about 17 grams of fiber per
day
all right and that's because only 10 of
their calories
come from plants
and 60 of their calories come from ultra
processed foods
typically where we you guessed about
this before
we extract the fiber
and we add in chemicals as preservatives
right or tolerance or whatever it may be
and isolated foods right and then we and
then you know we
then might
package it up and it like sits on the
shelf for 12 months and it's the exact
same
food on the day that you packaged it
like it has not degraded
or
you know decomposed in any way that's
actually disturbing food is meant to be
decomposed food has a life cycle
like our ability to create something
that never has a life cycle is means
that it's not really alive anymore
um so
anyway that's 60 of the average
americans diet
30 of our calories come from animal
products
you can consume all the animal products
that you want the average american
right now
uh eats their body weight
plus the body weight of a five-year-old
child
in animal products on a yearly basis wow
so the average intake of animal products
is uh meat by the way not including
dairy not including dairy yes
so
um and i believe not including fish
but the average american is consuming
220 pounds of me
and the average american only weighs 170
pounds
so 170 pounds their body weight plus a
50 pound child
uh that's how much meat they're eating
now
pounds of uh meat
well i can tell you how many grams of
fiber there are in 220 pounds of meat
zero
there's not even one
you get zero grams of fiber and meat
so
there are things about me that concern
me about their effect on the gut
microbiome
but one of the biggest issues
is that it's devoid of fiber
and so
we have constructed a diet that only has
10 of our diet that actually produces
the fiber that our gut microbes need to
thrive
and here we sit and the average american
is getting about 17 grams of fiber per
day the recommended amount of fiber for
a woman is 25 grams of fiber
the recommended amount of fiber for a
man is 38 grams of fiber and so here we
are and 95 of americans
yeah are not even getting the minimum
recommended recommended amount of fiber
if you are listening to this right now
and you're saying okay so what do i do
about it dr b
it is so straightforward and simple
because once again i told you i don't
count grams of fiber
i count plants
i don't count calories
i count plants i don't count macros i
count plants
count your plants i want people to be
inspired
to make diversity of plants the
centerpiece of their dietary choices
you're in the supermarket you're trying
to figure out what you're going to pick
up
you hear dr b from
your podcast come through their waves
and say diversity of plants yeah
you are cooking chili
you're in the kitchen
you could keep it super simple but you
know what
why not have five or six types of beans
in there dr b
diversity of plants
you are sitting down at the dinner table
and there is a wide array of plants
at that table and you get to choose
which ones you like
but dr b says diversity of plants
and so it's a way in which you can make
it your own and if you do this
and you really focus on this you make
this an important part of your dietary
approach
these concerns about inadequate fiber
consumption
they will go away because you will be
cranking up the plants in your diet
you will be moving towards a plant
predominant diet
possibly you will become like you and i
plant exclusive yeah and this will
transform your health right transform
your life
bring you great joy you don't have to
make compromises it can be in abundance
you can eat until you're full
and then you emerge from this delicious
plate and you say i feel great and alive
and that's
vibrant for every single person yeah
totally well you said that so well i
think so many people who are listening
to this are in the realm of caring about
their health most of my audience have
you know i think most people can come to
that consensus that like processed foods
ultra processed foods are not optimal
for our health the people who are
listening and tuning into this type of
podcast and it really comes down to the
decision and understanding of like okay
what exactly is the thing i need to
focus on here we know whole foods but is
it more plants is it more animal foods
is it more diversity like you're saying
should i be cutting out this or
including this and the way that you put
that is like very clear and simple and i
think it's really fascinating um let's
back it up with some science if we could
yeah
so
uh actually there was a study that came
out in 2014 that anyone can check out
perhaps we can put it in the show notes
but you can you can find this on google
you just quite simply type in the name
david
nature
2014 okay this will be the first study
to pop up it was by lawrence david first
name lawrence last name david he's from
duke university
and going back to
sort of the historical perspective on
what we understood about the gut
microbiome if we today we accept that we
can shape our diet with
or shape our microbiome with food
but if we go back to 2014
that actually wasn't really completely
clear
in humans
and so dr david
basically like this was not a diet wars
study this was hey
like i want to know what's going to
happen here so he set a group of people
up
with five days of a completely
plant-based diet
no animal products at all
high in fiber
and then
after a break
he flipped them over to a completely
animal-based diet
five days of that
no plants at all
no fiber
and what he did in these like these are
the most sort of radically extreme polar
opposite diets he wanted to see like
can i change a person's diet with this
stuff
so he checked their microbiome every
single day here's what he found
within 24 hours
there were already measurable deductible
differences within the gut microbiome
wow
the choices that you are making today
are affecting your gut microbiome
through today
and on an ongoing basis
within 48 hours there were actually
pretty significant changes in the gut
microbiome
in five days on a plant-based diet
people changed their gut and there was a
shift
there was a shift towards microbes that
we often find in our probiotics
we take them
as a capsule because it's like oh
those are healthy they're good for us as
humans
you don't have to do that
you can just feed them
and that's what they were demonstrating
in this study
high fiber diet
feeds the microbes
and going back to when you feed the
microbes fiber they transform it and
release short chain fatty acids which is
exactly what happened
higher levels of short chain fatty acids
in five days on a plant-based diet
flip side
what happened on five days of a diet
that was exclusively
meat dairy and eggs
it was just i would describe it as
disturbing
uh not moving the direction that i want
to go with my health
there were the emergence of bacteria
like bilophyl wadsworthia that has been
associated with inflammatory bowel
disease
bacteria species that have been
associated with colorectal cancer are
number two cause of cancer death in
america
in five days you are shifting your gut
and
increasing your risk not developing
colon cancer not developing inflammatory
bowel disease but you are setting
yourself up where if you have the wrong
genetic predisposition
you're setting yourself up for these
problems
do you happen to know if in the study
what kind of like animal products they
were using like factory farmed or if it
was like grass-fed grass finished or
this particularly
you know this was 2014
yeah so things that are trendy and
popular now were not included in the
study then because they were not trendy
or considered to be important right so
they were consuming animal products they
weren't consuming grass-fed
or you know raw dairy or something of
that variety
but to pretend that you would see a
radically different
uh result
from substituting those things in
is a bit silly okay so let's talk about
that i actually want to ask you about
that
so a lot of people will say well all
these studies showing that dairy is not
good for you is because they're using
pasteurized dairy none of them are like
testing against raw local grass-fed
dairy or grass-finished beef and things
so like what is your response to that my
response to that is that the area has
been very clearly associated with
prostate cancer and it's actually the
the protein in dairy that is most
strongly connected to that and the
protein doesn't change
whether it's pasteurized or not no it
doesn't change but pasteurization is the
destruction of the bacteria
and from my perspective i am so
you know this about me and i'm guessing
the listeners probably at this point
could figure out that i'm a big believer
in fermented food
i'm a big believer in living food right
like raw food
raw plants
they have a microbiome
and i see value to introducing those
microbes okay
so raw dairy has those microbes
right but um is cow's milk designed for
human consumption
like if we're talking about evolution
being important
did cows evolve to support healthy
humans
no
um that to me doesn't like if the
argument is going to ignore the science
which is showing us that there are these
risks with dairy consumption
and that those risks
like there's not really a way to rectify
it to make it seem that the microbes are
the critical piece
that are either there or not there and
therefore would change everything right
when we're connecting it to the dairy
proteins that are there
yeah um
then uh to me we're sort of deceiving
ourselves yeah to buy into it something
that's really more narrative based right
and if it's gonna be narrative-based
then it's about the story oh well these
are these are you know ancestral foods
yeah right so people had cows right
people were just trying to survive yeah
that i think is the most important piece
that people are missing like they're
looking at you know this ancestral diet
and going oh look it's natural for us
we've been doing this for thousands of
years but not realizing that one cow's
milk is physiologically designed for a
baby calf like not for anyone else just
like polar bear milk is for a baby polar
bear monkey milk is for a baby monkey
just like human breast milk is for a
human baby exactly and then you take in
the factors that it makes sense why our
species kept cows when they're traveling
across lands trying to find places to
settle down where they don't know what
the food source will be and to use cow's
milk as a way to survive but that
doesn't mean that's how we thrive
100 and you know like when did
refrigerators come along
yeah right like my dad when he was a kid
they still got ice blocks
they didn't even have an electric
refrigerator
so
we lived through a period of time where
there was food scarcity
and having access to high calorie foods
was
advantageous because it helped you to
address the food scarcity issue that
existed right so but um you know that
the evidence from my perspective is very
clear that
that
we are not living longer healthier lives
as a result of the consumption of these
particular foods yeah i still would like
to see
more like studies happen like that a
little i'm not sure if it's possible but
it will help people who are kind of in
this camp of like well of course
grassland's going to be healthier um or
getting like a truly quality source of
animal products compared to like factory
farm
i think most people can agree that's
better than factory farms so if we could
like see that studies and see how
drastic a difference that really would
be it'd be cool to see more of that but
like you said pasteurization doesn't
make that big a difference so if you're
going to study something like
apple sauce versus a whole apple
the results shouldn't be that different
in regards to your optimal health yeah
or the app you know the issue with the
apple sauce is that there can be other
ingredients that you add in so it's a
little bit tough but like flip side
do we expect that frozen broccoli
to like have a radical right because
frozen broccoli you know they will
blanch it
right like it's already been cooked
and then they freeze it
right so the microbiome the microbes are
destroyed right so do we expect that
frozen broccoli is going to be like
you know unhealthy yeah and that that
fresh broccoli is like this superfood
yeah no they're they're both great
and if there's a difference that exists
it's a minor difference right i think
people should eat frozen broccoli if
they want to yeah
so and i think real quick ellen just to
close out on this research study where
they did the five days of the
animal-based diet yeah not only were
these changes occurring in the gut
microbiome but let me take this even a
little bit further
there was the absence of short chain
fatty acids
if you believe what i'm saying
then you have to pay attention to that
and that's because there was no fiber in
the diet
when you pull the plug on the fiber
which is what most americans are doing
you can't expect your gut microbes to
manufacture something without the
ingredients right
and the last thing is and this was i
think quite interesting and disturbing
in five days
they actually saw antibiotic resistance
forming in the gut microbiome
wow whoa okay
so how does that work um how would you
develop antibiotic resistance from
eating animal products is that the
animal product
well
uh i don't think it's actually the
animal per se like if you were to go and
go hunting for example i don't think you
would develop antibiotic resistance from
that
but
in this particular case
70 to 80 percent of antibiotics in the
united states are not given to humans
they're a part of animal agriculture
so the
animal gets hopped up on antibiotics why
because actually
going back to the effect of our microbes
on our metabolism
when you destroy the microbes
the animal gains weight
a pig
can be fed the exact same food the exact
same number of calories
but if you hop it up on antibiotics and
you destroy their microbiome they will
gain 15 percent more weight
and pounds translate into dollars in
that industry
so in this case
they're eating uh the animal bot animal
rich
diet
and they're discovering that the
antibiotics being administered to these
animals is likely the cause of
antibiotic resistance in the gut in just
five days so i think it's i think it's
like fascinating to imagine that our
dietary choices have an effect on us
within 24 hours and you could make a
choice of a path that empowers your gut
with fiber that
allows you to create these healing
anti-inflammatory short-chain fatty
acids through a plant-based diet
or
you can choose a different path
that in just five days
predisposes you to the risks of
inflammatory bowel disease colorectal
cancer and perhaps gives you antibiotic
resistance it's not a hard choice that
is so fascinating i love this
conversation and i feel like there's so
much more depth that we can go into and
we are going to do this with a round two
people are gonna have to wait for round
two but i'm really excited for round two
because we're going to get into the
nitty gritty of like what is it exactly
that heals the gut if you're struggling
with gut issues why is it that you know
if you will do elimination types you
feel better for a certain period of time
things like that and i can't wait to get
into that we'll talk about gluten we'll
talk about oh my gosh i can't even
remember i wrote a bunch of things down
but it's going to be so great well i
think the bottom line is that i i do
want people to hear this that
you know i'm here today
to get you like excited
about eating this way
[Music]
but there is no doubt that there are
some of you who will come back and say
but dr b i don't feel good
and i want to create a path
that allows you to not
like not just to get rid of those
feelings
i want you to feel great
i want to feel like you're thriving and
in complete alignment
and so that's what will um focus on when
we come back for round two but in the
meantime i just if you don't mind i'd
love to give a quick shout out yes
to
if you are interested in these topics
my first book fiber fueled came out in
may of 2020. it's so good everyone go
read it please and it's been amazing the
support that i've received from people
like yourself ellen and i'm so grateful
to everyone who reaches out to me and
tell me how this book changed their life
but i felt like there was unfinished
business at the end of fiberfield from
my perspective as a doctor
because as i just said there are people
who want to eat this way
and they feel that they struggle
and i
those are the people that i spend my
life trying to help and in your first
book you're talking about how those are
the people who actually need this
information the most 100 these are the
people who need this the most like the
person who struggles the most to eat a
plant-rich diet is also the person who
actually needs it the most right
and so i wanted to create
a resource
um a to almost like a tool kit for gut
health
where
you're this person
or even if you're not that person and
you just want to eat more plants
and you want to do it in the most
abundant beautiful way that brings you
great joy okay i want to help all of you
get there yeah and so i created a
cookbook
it's called the fiberfield cookbook it
is a cookbook 125 recipes
beautiful color photography
but
beyond that it also is a protocol
for people who have
food intolerances i'm going to teach you
how to identify and fix those issues
i also am going to teach you how to
sprout
how to make sourdough bread
how to ferment food
and yeah the food is delicious just like
in the first book amazing i'm so excited
for your second book it's gonna be such
a hit and i think it's going to help so
many people both of those together
really set the foundation for people how
how to heal their gut and to like
understand what they're doing too so for
those of you who were excited by this
conversation
um check me out on instagram yes
facebook the gut health md
check out my website theplantfedgut.com
join my email list
and um perhaps check out my book fiber
fueled and pre-order the fiber fields
cookbook which comes out may 17th and i
will put those links below in the show
notes and description box for you guys
so cool thank you so much for being here
this was such a fascinating conversation
thank you ellen was great see you next
time
[Music]
you